piccolissimo spoiler vi chiedo scusa se
non sono per me mai mai mai mai
da una parte è perché è sera quindi sto
evitando magari di urlare ottenere un
tono troppo alto però vabbè ci facciamo
le chiacchiere un pochino più è anche un
pochino perché oggi è stata una giornata
tosta sto iniziando ad accusare e quindi
c'è un pochino l'umore il mood che fa su
e giù seggio quindi non so come andrà
questa chiacchiera però volevo farla
tutti i costi e dello stanco di trovare
delle scuse pur di ritardare nella
speranza magari di stare un pochino più
a pallettoni è stato meno a pallettoni
spero che mi possiate perdonare
sai che devi fare il premio on no rec
premi rec
vedrai che ti piera sa bene allora
stamattina su instagram ho fatto la
domanda che secondo me è fondamentale in
questo periodo sia come state poi
sembrano domanda stupida ma secondo me
una domanda che non viene fatta
abbastanza arrivano un sacco di pareri
discordanti contrastanti c'è chi è
felice e ci sono invece persone che
stanno avendo gli incubi ecco perché
credo che sia arrivato il momento in
questa puntata di commento commenti di
metterci a fare una chiacchiera su come
stiamo passando questo periodo di
quarantena partiamo subito io sto da 10
mai stata così attiva in vita mia faccio
cannes dell onda la faccio candele
decoro vasi studio il coreano lo sai che
un mio amico vorrebbe tipo iniziare a
fare o francese o spagnolo
io pure mi sono messo a fare un pochino
di cose sto cercando di imparare a fare
il luogo in camicia non ci sono ancora
riuscito traccia proprio a cagare testo
cerca di fare cacare un altro che sto
facendo un sacco in questo periodo e
suonare il pianoforte non so perché non
meno sono cacato per una vita sta lì ha
aperto scrivo canzoni e che non dice
perché scrive canzoni non sei un
musicista o
cioè nessuno e nulla finché non si
inizia a farlo sto perdendo così tanto
la testa che sto facendo le sedute di
terapia con le videochiamate posso dirti
che in realtà è una mossa molto molto
intelligente che stimo e apprezzo nel
senso che dico solo che sono scese in
garage fissato lavatrice che girava per
due ore anonimo grazie tranquilla guarda
tanto mettiamo in anonimo tutto quanto
ti dico solo che io ultimamente non
riesco a prendere il latte
sto cercando di evitare di uscire il più
possibile da casa e quindi faccio la
spesa online quando posso avevo i
cereali e avevo solo l'acqua frizzante
però non erano in me sono al settimo
mese di gravidanza non è per niente
facile posso solo immaginare che cosa tu
stia passando lo so se visto anche clio
ha dovuto prendere delle decisioni
abbastanza forti lei vive a new york in
america e ha deciso di lasciare la città
perché li sta succedendo un delirio cioè
mentre noi ci chiudiamo in casa ma se
ricevete a suonare in balcone col
mandolino e abbiamo perché in italy i
nostri problemi in america comprano le
pistole per difendersi io sono sicuro
che questo periodo finirà non so se ci
insegnerà qualcosa
secondo me no anche perché il virus non
è collegato con il rispetto l'uno nei
confronti dell'altro nel collegato
nemmeno con il rispetto nei confronti
dell'ambiente sicuramente la terra sta
ottenendo dei benefici ma sono dei
benefici collaterali non sono legati al
coronavirus non so se è chiaro quando
riprenderemo la nostra vita adulta cosa
della quale se ne fregherà il pianeta e
soprattutto la mia paura è che rimanga
un ansia nei confronti degli altri e che
quindi si finisca solamente per
aumentare la distanza tra le persone e
stiamo facendo anche dato per accorciare
o anche se distanti peccato continua a
ribadirlo il tempo cura tutte le ferite
ma cancella anche un sacco di
insegnamenti e se non è questo l'anno
vedremo fra quelli io sto molto bene era
una sociale e solitaria prima lo sono
ancora non sono mai uscita di casa lo
sai che sono uscito una sola volta per
buttare la spazzatura e un paio di volte
per fare lo scambio della spesa che
avete al portone tipo ciao ciao addio ma
poi viene il resto social capitario
buon esempio evitando di mettere piede
fuori casa anche perché posso lavorare
da casa e anche perché non ho parenti o
persone che devo andare a visitare o
accudire esistono verso restano c'è
tutto questo e non riesco a immaginare
nemmeno come possano fare ad andare
avanti con questo stress
io sono bloccata in germania con un
coinquilino che tossisce notte e giorno
e non vuole fare il tampone ma non
esiste un ma perché perché io a volte ci
pensano le scuole meno immaginario
quante persone possono avere in realtà
il virus
ovviamente i conteggi sono quelli del
tampone quindi di base dovrebbero essere
di più molte più dicono tipo dieci volte
tanto che allegria una merda la bulimia
si è fatta ancora più stronzo non dire
il mio nome presa non lo farei
a dimenticavo il mio fratello non fa
altro che sottolinearlo prendendomi per
il culo tutto il giorno è come si può
prendere in giro un problema di questo
tipo non ho idea credo che veramente
questo periodo da una parte tirerà
sicuramente fuori il meglio di noi ma
dall'altra tira fuori dei mostri
io in primis dove dovrebbe un po
vergognarsi e tu non dovresti criticarti
così tanto perché credo che sia
veramente veramente veramente difficile
al momento tosto perché improvvisamente
le persone non possono più lasciarsi
distrarre dalla vita ma sono costrette a
rendersi conto con chi stanno in casa
oggi sono un po triste
quindi più difficile commentare quello
che mi sta dicendo mi dispiace mi
dispiace perché immagino quanto sia
difficile in questo momento dover
convivere con se stessi o magari con
altre persone e renderti conto che non è
facile vivere con queste persone e col
modo in cui queste prendono in giro la
tua convivenza con te stesso diversi
auguri
io ti auguro di trovare la forza però mi
rendo conto che una cosa che dipende
molto da te e voglio solo che tu non ti
senta sbagliata
poi l'ho inserito un pressing se questa
forza sembra impossibile da trovare
e una cosa che mi dico sempre quando si
gratta il fondo un pochino si deve
essere felici perché non si può scendere
più in basso e si può solamente risalire
io ti auguro di alzare la testa e di
trovare quella forza col cuore del
lavoro
oddio stanno arrivando tutti i messaggi
tristi non ho mai visto piangere mia
madre in 19 anni di vita mia madre
un'infermiera cremona in terapia
intensiva piangere ogni giorno e non so
cosa fare è così difficile vederlo a
pezzi tua mamma è un'eroina innanzitutto
insieme a tutti quanti gli altri medici
che stanno veramente dando l'anima per
il nostro paese per i nostri malati e il
loro lavoro il loro sudore le loro
lacrime devono veramente essere un
monito per tutti quanti noi nell
impegnarci perché se loro sono dei
professionisti che hanno fatto una
scelta di vita
una scelta che seguono maniera così
forte noi pure siamo dei cittadini
italiani ragazzi e abitare questo mondo
ci deve assolutamente imporre delle
regole perché altrimenti siamo solamente
gli egoisti di merda due figli un marito
la cagnolina in calore è un tumore da
operare chissà quando l'ansia pura cioè
noi che stiamo a casa non abbiamo niente
da fare
niente da perdere l'unico nostro
problema è mi annoio
cioè siamo dei cazzoni privilegiati
ragazzi ti mando un abbraccio 90 guarda
spero veramente che vada tutto tutto
bene tutto
questa quarantena stupiranno fare un
lato che non mi piace di me i ragazzi
scusate mi sudano gli occhi ma ciò che
la prende bene in b lavoro venerdì 17
aprile
che culo da remoto senza tesi senza
corona senza gioia senza corona meglio
la loro aspetta o aspetta quattro mesi
ma che ti costa ma che ti frega è preso
una laurea e che dovevi stare lì a
sbocciare ubriacarti e fare la pazza
capisco che tu voglia farlo per poi
farlo anche tra qualche mese io ho
scoperto di avere più risorse di quanto
pensassi sto facendo più cose ora di
prima beata te io a volte sto a fissare
la parete bianca e spero di colorarla
con lo sguardo mi dichiaro il giorno
prima dell'inizio della quarantena
ancora attendo risposta beh credo che la
tua risposta sia arrivata e poi strano è
perché in realtà questo è un periodo che
qua ci stanno un sacco di morti di [ __ ]
in giro che non sanno dove andare
a infilarlo prenderebbero un vaso da
terra e lo zapper ebbero a colpi di
carne ecco sto morendo di solitudine a
ti capisco io ho deciso proprio di
rimanere da solo nel senso che io nasato
un pochino il fatto che sarebbe arrivata
una forma di 40 euro a un certo punto
saremmo dovuti rimanere a casa
ok ho avuto degli amici che mi hanno
detto sentivo test brigati sbrigati ma
perché non vieni da noi vieni da noi
prima che magari dicano o impongano le
persone di non poter più uscire di casa
o di non poter più andare a visitare
gente fare tutte quelle cose che
effettivamente ci sono state ordinate di
non fare io però so anche che molto
probabilmente in compagnia
avrei rischiato di commettere degli
omicidi
veramente non so quanto possa durare
questo momento questo periodo e le
statistiche secondo me mi fanno essere
un pochino per sinistra cioè credo che
sarà di più di quello che pensiamo
spero di sbagliarmi però avrei ucciso
verso le quali avrei vissuto il problema
è che convivo con me stesso e con tutte
le personalità quindi gli dico con le
stesso a volte vorrei picchiarmi non lo
facciano davanti a testa alta alti e
bassi ma di base sempre come una vera
regina dei draghi
ho iniziato a parlare con un ragazzo che
mi piace da tanto ci facciamo compagnia
distanza dai una cosa carina e dico una
cosa impopolare è una cosa carina anche
al di là di come andrà credo che
situazioni così assurde possano portare
ad avvicinamenti di questo tipo non so
poi se siano avvicinamenti duraturi o se
siano avvicinamenti momentanei però sono
contento che tu abbia una persona con la
quale fare competenze per ovviamente
questa cosa possa crescere soprattutto
spero che possa continuare a portarti
serenità senza lavoro senza soldi un
affitto da pagare più annessi niente
legna per scaldarsi questo qui è un
pensiero che mi sono fatto un sacco ed è
qui che vorrei un attimo cercare di
capire se sta tenendo fatto un
ragionamento anche su se i cittadini se
oltre a quelli che sono i consigli
sanitari stanno venendo presi dei
provvedimenti economici nei confronti
determinate persone che io vi giuro
ragazzi a volte ci penso io a volte ci
penso magari delle persone che già di
base hanno delle difficoltà quando
lavorano e che magari adesso si trovano
a casa e non possono lavorare e non
sanno come pagare gli affitti pagare il
cibo pagare magari non lo so delle
medicine o anche semplicemente internet
che in questo periodo salva cioè salva
insieme ai libri salve insieme a tutte
quelle che sono salve insieme a tutte
quelle che sono quelle forme di
intrattenimento che per kate hanno un
costo e io mi chiedo e voglio capire
veramente se il governo sta pensando a
qualcosa perché non so quanto si possa
poi pretendere non parlo per me ma penso
alle persone che devono comunque
continuare a pagare tasse pagare quello
senza poter guadagnare in un momento in
cui la propria vita e messa in stallo in
pausa in maniera anche così poco chiara
io veramente spero che ci sia una forma
di attenzione nei confronti di persone
che già stanno avendo a che fare con una
paura comune per tutti ma non possono
non possono e non devono e non debbono
perchè sarebbe una vergogna da parte
della nostra classe politica abbandonare
persona la propria disperazione e
togliere alle persone la dignità e
togliere le persone alla dignità di una
e togliere alle persone la dignità di
una tranquillità economica dovuta in
questo momento non si possono aggiungere
anche pensieri di quel tipo specialmente
il momento in cui viene chiesto a delle
persone di rimanere a casa altrimenti
specialmente il momento in cui viene
chiesto delle persone di rimanere a casa
scrive senza lavoro senza soldi un
affitto da pagare più annessi questa
persona cosa deve fare è costretta a
uscire una persona così che cosa deve
fare
viene costretta a fare delle cazzate
bisogna stare vicino a queste persone
non si possono lasciare sole non si può
fare una cosa così ed è compito del
nostro stato che sta facendo tanto a
livello sanitario fare altrettanto per
queste persone
sto mangiando quanto una scrofa batti
cinque sto facendo lo schifo leggevano
altro momento che diceva sto ingrassando
aspetto dove non anche il ca tesoro e
mettete in filastò ingrassando allora
sto mangiando anch'io come uno schifo ma
ogni giorno alle 17 mi sto allenando su
instagram il live
allora brave ragazze vi invito a farlo
tutti quanti si chiama fisico da coop in
questa rubrica gabriele pazzesco fa fare
ogni volta degli allenamenti diversi
qualche giorno fa abbiamo fatto il culo
una virus che era tutto l'allenamento di
squat fa molto ridere e secondo me è un
bel modo per rimanere insieme io non ho
mai avuto
diciamo non so se si vede perché non
sono perfette queste luci ma io è da un
po che non avevo questo braccia questi
muscoli e questa è una cosa positiva
perché comunque anche se sto mangiando
solo costretto a fare questa cosa e mi
aiuta tantissimo se non avessi gli
allenamenti per il fisico della covip
non so cosa farei quindi venire tutti su
instagram che vi aspettiamo ogni giorno
17 tranne la domenica io mi sono
lasciato il giorno stesso che uscì il
primo decreto sto vivendo una rottura
nella sua abitudine anche questa tosta
ed calcola che non sei sola la sorella
di una mia amica si è lasciata dopo
cinque anni stava con un ragazzo e tre
di convivenza è andato a vedere dalla
vicina follia follie foley le che mi
dover sposare a maggio immagina la mia
ansia non parlerò perché non voglio
aggiungere però dai la cosa positiva è
che vuoi ancora sposarti
no ma solo io sto una crema o finalmente
il tempo di fare le cose che non faccio
da tanto guarda ti posso dire una cosa
io a volte sento quello che mi stai
dicendo celere a volte solo a questo
momento d'acqua etico lo devo fare
questo non devo fare quell altro però
allo stesso tempo c'è l'ansia del dover
fare se non fai niente di fermi e se ti
fermi crolli e per quanto tutto il mondo
si è rallentato io non voglio usarlo
come una giustificazione quindi sì ho un
sacco di tempo per divertirmi per
pagarmi ma sto cercando di concentrarmi
tantissimo per esempio su dei progetti
di scrittura che o non stanno andando
tanto avanti ma mi impegnerò affinché
questo succeda e quindi testa alta e
dura mia madre e covip positiva e io mi
sento un verme inutile mi dispiace un po
degli amici che hanno dei cari
di rianimazione che sono positivi al co
lead e comprendo il dolore
posso solo immaginarlo ragazze c'è gente
che non può essere almeno ricoverata il
papa più nemico di una mia amica non può
essere ricoverato che è allucinante
ragazze allucinante se ci pensate quello
però che ti posso dire è che comprendo
la tristezza ma non puoi nemmeno darti
verbo inutile tesoro che c'entri tu cosa
vuoi fare
se non hai le ali e hai le mani non puoi
volare quindi fatti forte io ti auguro
tutto il meglio del mondo ma non ti
trattare così perché non te lo meriti
non te lo meriti assolutamente sono
stata single per un anno inizia
quarantena e mi chiedono di uscire
dio mi ama non scopo da mesi incontro
uno fantastico ma niente quarantena
ragazzi questo ragazzo il calcolo delle
probabilità cioè ci dovrà essere per
forza qualcuno che oltre a mollarsi lì
lì per iniziare qualcosa non so perché
lo dico congo lando non è che sia felice
però mi fa sorridere perché proprio
diciamo la rappresentazione del mai una
gioia in solo piano di stefar falli e il
merda invece in casa cos'è che far
uscire le farfalline n'è andato al mare
qualcosa l'anima nel nata male sommersa
da compiti nemmeno il tempo di annoiarmi
odio latino come che sta funzionando
esattamente la scuola perché io ho visto
gente che fa lezioni online
non ho capito bene come funzioni se si
fanno durante gli orari scolastici o se
sono degli appuntamenti un pochino
sparsi durante la giornata
ho capito mi stavo frequentando da due
mesi con un ragazzo ci siamo a cannati
in videochiamata sempre meglio che su
whatsapp chiuso due giorni fa col mio
ragazzo mensile netflix caduto e sono
senza soldi ciclo una merda mamma mia
madre santa però aspetta ho appena visto
una cosa qui abbiamo kitty butter io
sono costretta a vivere col mio ex fai
tu wow wow oh wow oh wow wow wow non
voglio nemmeno no no basta chiudiamo
tutto ho dato per oggi chiudiamo bastini
finito ciao ragazzi ciao
siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
chiacchiera e vi ringrazio per tutti i
messaggi che mi avete mandato su
instagram cercando di farvi passa il
tempo come possa questo youtube su
instagram fare il cretino io ti mando un
abbraccio enorme mi raccomando cercate
di sato guardarvi stare a casa per voi
per i vostri cari in qualunque sia la
vostra situazione non buttatevi giù o se
vi buttate giù e cadete sappiate che c'è
sempre tempo per rimettersi verticali
detto ciò mi mando un bacio e ci vediamo
domenica con una puntata di cui ci sono
buttata che continuerò a girare da solo
non ho idea di che cosa preparare
fatemelo sapere anche qua sotto magari
in una idea che posso fare a casa da
solo lotto che sono enrico gianmarco
lavinia nove zone
ciao